india right now that comes out and india
says
we're banning more chinese apps as part
of its digital campaign to pressure
beijing indiana bans 43 more chinese
india
bans 43 more chinese apps in new delhi's
latest move to pressure china and the
online industry as tensions fester
following a deadly border clash between
the neighboring countries india's
minister of electronics and information
technology issued
an order citing growing concerns about
data security and blocking the chinese
apps effectively restricting china's
access to one of the largest and fastest
growing online markets in the world
tuesday and tuesday's actions
bring the total number of chinese app
bans to india to more than 170 apps have
been banned in india
170 chinese apps have been banned in
india the bands are what some indian
poli
politicians have called a digital strike
against china
after a june clash along their disputed
border and himalayas killed 20 indian
soldiers
so the the point i'm trying to make to
you is do you think
these guys are going to come out and
they're going to say no china's been
trying to abuse their relationship with
america they've been trying to get all
this intel
you know all these made in china plan
which one of their plans was to come in
infiltrate we'll invest into your
business but you got to give us all the
rights to your technology and if we
recreate it in china
you want zero of it it's ours so give us
all your inventory
of what you're creating this is what
their plans have been you think biden's
gonna hold them accountable
i highly doubt that i think china's
celebrating right now
i think china's celebrating right now so
short-term victory long-term loss is
what i see for
what i foresee taking place there and by
the way
if you're listening i'm not telling you
the market is going to take a hit i
actually think market's going to go up
the next couple years
i don't think mark mark is going to take
it my prediction is the following
my prediction is cases are up cases are
i may be wrong cases are up cases are up
cases are up
boom inauguration cases are down
record-breaking cases are down
california has made the turn
you know new york has made the turn the
biden administration approach to the way
the pandemic is handling
look at the confidence in america and
the market's going to go up
and if they sustain this market going up
the next couple years
and in 2024 re-election time if powell
continues the zero percent interest rate
the market's not going to take a big hit
if there's not a big strike there
probably going to be a re-election i
don't know if it's going to be biden
it could be somebody else coming into
office whether kamala takes over because
i don't know if we can have an 82 year
old president
and we don't even know what's going to
happen with this health a lot of people
are comparing
a kamala harris to a lyndon johnson type
of person where
you know john f kennedy is no longer
with us biden's no longer going to be
with us kamala's going to be the
president and maybe her intentions are
going to be
to drive a little bit more progressive
we don't know that all i'm saying is i
don't think there's going to be a crazy
thing happening to the market the next
couple years i do see
the numbers the data the fear tactics of
covet going away effective january 1st
that's my prediction what part of that
has to do with the vaccine a big part of
that has to do to say
america's calmer more civil less rights
less protesting you're going to see
videos of showing
trump administration look what happened
to the streets you're going to show
by doing the administration let's go on
what's going on the streets but what
they're not going to show is they're not
going to say
trump's administration here's what
happened in the streets
the folks on the opposite side riot loot
hurt businesses
but on this side when they lose the
opposite side
doesn't go right and loot they just take
the loss and they say we can't stay just
don't take our guns leave us alone
we'll go about our business and we'll
come back i think that's what's going to
be shown in america the average voter
that's in the middle is going to say
dude i don't know what the hell is going
on but all i know is when a person like
on trump is a president there's rights
when a person like biden's president
there's no rights and i'm more
comfortable i just want my kids to be
safe this is why i like it when a
democrat's in office
i think that messaging if the marketing
is right you're going to see a lot of
that messaging taking place in 2021
again
i may be wrong i'm simply making a
prediction of what i foresee taking
place in 2020
are you still at five percent i am uh
well that
five percent adam five percent i would
never take a five percent bet
five percent bet to me is like it's done
but my five percent bet is
sidney powell giuliani if they have
anything
show the damn thing already yeah but i
will tell you this and i told you this
the other day and i'm not changing my
position
if you lose there's nothing worse
like we teach our guys because we have
we have a very competitive environment
you've seen it
of course but prior to conventions i
always
teach our guys one message and i've been
doing this for 18 years
i talk to our guys about how to lose i
talk to them
specifically when i know who's going to
lose i will talk to our group and i say
let me explain to you sore losers
let me explain to you how you're
supposed to lose when you lose
and i'll show video i took our guys to
breakers and i showed the last dance i
said look how jordan lost to detroit
pistons
look how isaiah thomas lost to the
chicago bulls
that guy didn't make it on the dream
team because of this guy if you lose
lose if you lose don't [ __ ] about it
just move on i hope fair for what he's
done up to this point
trump voter fraud all this other stuff
fine fair if you think that's what's
going on fair
but i hope when it's final and it's done
and it's lost
i hope it's we lost let's see what we
can do the next four years to compete
because if you don't do that it is it
doesn't look good on your legacy
if you lose you lose man by the way you
have to realize policies wise which we
think i'm leaning towards policy-wise
you think i'm leaning towards a biden
administration policy to make china
stronger what do you think i'm leaning
policy-wise
what do you think okay i'm pretty public
about it i'm not holding i'm a
capitalist yeah
i want small businesses to have some
protection i want them to be fine but at
the same time
if you lose you got to make your move if
you don't
it's not a good look for you legacy wise
it's not a good look for you
legacy wise yeah nobody likes a sore
loser uh back to the point of uh
you know what's gonna happen i do really
think that so much of it rides on the
senate race though
uh in terms of the general public that's
not no question about it you're right
because the general
public to your point of you know well
biden's in office everything's calm
that's the the hood ornament or the
peacock feathers that
you know 85 percent of society that
doesn't watch news
24 25 hours a day uh you know
realizes and so that's why i think a guy
like biden wins versus trump i mean it's
it's no different than say going into a
uh
a brain surgeon's office you know you
got one guy that's this nice calm
smooth talking you know makes you feel
super comfortable about the surgery and
then this next guy his hair is on fire
he's talking about how dangerous it is
you know but
let's just say hypothetically the guy
with the hair on his fire a guy with his
hair on fire
is a much better surgeon you're going to
feel more comfortable with this other
guy if you don't know [ __ ] about surgery
i think that that's happened largely
here is that most people just want to be
put at ease
where that only works is if the senate
remains in republican hands because a
lot of the protections you're talking
about maintain
that status by by having a split
government that way i agree if they
don't
then i can see so to me like i i agree
with your assessment if
it stays that way i think the market
will go up because everybody's like [ __ ]
biden's doing a great job everything's
good you know because there's that
you think if it's all three market takes
a hit i do yeah okay
so so i don't i don't disagree there i
don't disagree with you there
uh but but my my perspective is more
coming from the optics of how the media
is going to sell it regardless of
whether they have all three or two out
of three
yeah i think the way it's going to be
sold is look how peaceful america is you
know this whole america first now it's
more you know america's back and
what's really back with america being
back is high taxes back what is back all
is going back to war back or is it
sending our troops back to warba what is
back we're gonna find it what is really
back that's what we want to know what is
back so
i don't disagree with you there